[موسيقى]
هنا في مصنع Oh Pasta الأصلي بالقرب من
نابولي ، حيث تلتقي 50 عامًا من تقاليد الطهي الإيطالية
بالابتكار في وقت سابق من هذا
العام ، حيث يتم طحن هذه الآلات أو تم تشغيل
Quetta و spaghetti بواسطة
وقود هيدروجين جديد ممزوج بالغاز الطبيعي ،
وهي تجربة متطورة في أوروبا  التي
تعرض الهيدروجين الأخضر كمصدر للطاقة النظيفة
للمستقبل بهذا الحجم
الذي يحدث وتوقعنا جميعًا أن
خلط الهيدروجين والإنتاج الصناعي
هو تجربة يتم إجراؤها بواسطة أحد
أكبر مزودي الغاز في أوروبا ،
وهناك ضغط متزايد من
شركات الطاقة لتغيير استراتيجيات أعمالهم
وتعتقد الشركة أنه قد يكون لديها الجواب من
خلال إدخال 10٪ فقط من الهيدروجين في
شبكة الغاز الحالية الخاصة بها ،
وتعتقد الشركة أن انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون ستنخفض
بمقدار 5 ملايين طن سنويًا
وتراهن على أنه في غضون ثلاثة عقود
سيوفر الهيدروجين الأخضر ربع
نعتقد أن طاقة إيطاليا ستصل إلى ما
بين 3 و 5 في المائة في عام 2030
ونرى أنها ستزيد من طاقتك  إلى 25 في المائة بحلول عام 2050 ،
نرى تكاليف تسمح بحدوث هذه
الثورة دون
الحاجة إلى إعانات أو ضرائب ، وبالتالي فهي
طريقة لتغذية الصفقة
الخضراء التي تنتج الهيدروجين الأخضر من مصادر الطاقة المتجددة
لا تزال باهظة التكلفة ، والكهرباء
التي تنتجها الألواح الشمسية وتوربينات الرياح
يقسم الماء إلى هيدروجين
وأكسجين من خلال التحليل الكهربائي ،
ثم يتدفق الهيدروجين إلى المصانع ومحطات الخدمة
، ويمكنه تشغيل
مركبات وقود الإنتاج الصناعي أو تخزينه
للاستخدام المستقبلي ، ولكن وسط زيادة
الطلب العام على البلدان لإبراز
الطاقة النظيفة وأي حزم لاسترداد فيروس كورونا
، تعلن العديد من الحكومات
عن  مشاريع الهيدروجين الخضراء
كجزء من خطط التحفيز الاقتصادي ، هناك
اعتراف أكبر بأننا بحاجة إلى القيام
بشيء الآن لا يمكننا الانتظار ،
تنخفض التكاليف وتنخفض
بشكل كبير بينما يبحث المستهلكون أيضًا
عن المزيد من المنتجات الصديقة للبيئة
وهذا معًا يؤدي إلى هذا السوء
ميزة لم نشهدها في
الماضي مع انخفاض التكلفة  جي والتجارب
مثل هنا في أصل مصنع المعكرونة
يمكن أن يصبح الهيدروجين الأخضر لاعبًا رئيسيًا
في نظام الطاقة العالمي في منطقة جون
تيفت في سي إن إن